miss Bergen and I are here to test the
wisdom of the adage it's better to give
than to receive
hey Candace right Ellie and that's why
I'm going to give the award for the best
achievement in sound sound sound you
believe that I landed early check with
me later campus the nominees for sound
john Aldred and of the thousand days
William Edmondson and David Dakin door
for Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid
Robert Martin and Clem Portman for gay
legally Jack Solomon and Murray spit
back for Hello Dolly and less free Holtz
and Arthur pianted OSI for marooned may
we have the envelope I'll open it
candace say the magic word the winners
are jack solomon and marie Spivak for
Hello Dolly
I wish to thank the members of the
Academy mr. Ernest Lehman mr. Gene Kelly
and especially the members of the 20th
century facts a department who worked
with me on Hello Dolly namely the James
Cochran Douglas Williams Vinton Vernon
Ted Soderbergh Edward farewell and Jack
Sullivan I'm very grateful thank
everybody